[Musique]
paul bocuse j'ai un problème j'ai des
amis que j'aime beaucoup qui sont
végétariens ils viennent dîner à 5
alors je voudrais un plat pour
végétariens c'est à dire sans viande
offre mais on peut faire un poivron à la
basquaise c'est à dire qu'il remplit de
fromage demi sel et qui est asean et de
paprika c'est un poivron qu'on peut
manger aussi mais je pense alors 2 c'est
très agréable l'été parce qu on le sert
froid et c'est très bon mais 600 majid a
rien derrière j'avais envie de faire un
pigeon à l'ail alors qu'est ce qu'ils
vont devenir mon pigeon là ils vont
manger de l'ail à nos amis voilà mais
déjà c'est une fois vous et on a envie
de mettre derrière un pigeon à l'ail
vous avez avec un corner avec les
gousses d'ail entières
parce que vous savez comme retire un
pigeon si on retire le pigeon avec les
gousses d'ail entières et à la fin de
cuisson on sort à l'intérieur l'aïe qui
est à l'intérieur des gousses vous
écraser sa plus du tout goût dice est
très bon et vous lier ça avec un petit
peu de crème et vous servez ses pigeons
avec cette purée d'ail c'est une cure
derrière donc on va on peut mettre une
belle brioche c'est à dire qu'on peut
acheter une traite à briller dell
brioches pour mes végétarien alors là
ils mangeront les poivrons et dessin
avec une avec une crème anglaise
et puis quoi boire avec les pigeons à la
et moi je pensais un corner savez c'est
qu'on a ces vins de côtes du rhône lundi
qui sera fêté un trait assez costaud
savez ce qui pousse en eau les coteaux
c'est très très dur j'ai jamais visiter
les vignobles devront du rhône c'est
merveilleux parce que c'est tout un
espalier c'est très bon puis si l'on
parle côtes du rhône dont le corps n'a
s'ils peuvent boire un côtes-du-rhône
ils peuvent voir un ermitage ils peuvent
barrage art au 9 mai on va peut-être
passer à la recette
alors d'abord leurs plats non non classé
c'est simple il faut les poivrons les
voiliers les poivrons sont très beaux
ils sont verts et rouges d'ailleurs je
pense que des couleurs basques eux le
vert et le rouge qu'elle est plus fort
c'est leur ai même jamais sinon parce
que vous confondez avec le piment
il y a la même chose que ça mais qui est
plus petit qu est le piment qui est
beaucoup plus petit mais qui est très
fier c'est le piment rouge que plus fort
tandis que ça c'est du point feront pas
du piment et non mail vert rouge il est
fort le piment est une autre trace c'est
à dire il ya le pi mal profond ça ce
sont des donc ça ce sont deux profs des
poivrons pour pour cinq ans mais combien
vaut 800
mais après on peut le garder pour un
autre jour elle mangeait comme fromage
du paprika c'est à dire du paprika faut
trouver en général on essaye de trouver
un bon paprika que papy tard de montgri
du cumin inquiets du cumin c'est à dire
les graines de carvi vous savez c'est en
général ce qui met sur le masculin
exactement lé même du fait du poids du
persil 1 oignon
on a tous de l'échalote delahaye et si
on a un peu de ciboulette et de fines
herbes se néglige rien donc on va
commencer la recette voilà c'est très
facile on va commencer par hacher
l'oignon
alors là il faut larcher l'oignon très
très faim parce que c'est très important
il faut faire un oignon très très très
faim pour qu'ils soient fondus dans le
beurre et la toujours la même chose on
va faire fondre l'oignon dans le beurre
parce que c'est très important pour pas
que c'est le goût de nyon pour pas que
ça revienne
il faut que les animaux soient sains du
riz avec l'arrivée c'était beaucoup plus
lisa oui ça c'est très très importante
voilà votre mieux cacher bien fin et à
ce moment là vous prenez à peu près 20 g
de beurre
vous mettez ce saint lazare petit cul de
poule
vous mettez votre union dedans pourquoi
faire servir une casserole du moment que
un cul-de-poule en inox ça va très bien
sur le feu et là vous faites l'avait
tourné
oui vous faites tomber votre vos oignons
fait tomber vos oignons au beurre un
doux souvenir d'une foi qui sera tombé
au beurre je m'en vais en profiter pour
acheter un petit peu l'échalote tension
qui vole pas oui bah c'est là bas c'est
pas de ma faute c'est parce que le feu
est très fort et ça continue à cuire 2 à
continuer à fermer alors géant chinois
l'échalote georges un petit peu mon ait
bien fini voilà bon alors ça y est c'est
bien fondu à ce moment là je fais fondre
dans mon corps et mes oignons 2
cuillères de paprika même pour 5
oui pour sa croisière à café de paprika
force voilà et ça s'est bien fondu de 5
alors le nions le beurre a pris 4 way
s'est tous bien fondus là dedans et là
maintenant une fois que c'est là on va
mettre les missels d'un an par personne
à peu près will roll hachémi oui parce
que pour gagner du pauvre et comme vous
dit il n'y a pas de perte puisque on le
garde leur élan pour faire du fromage
dans la glacière
rires oui d'un qe3 et là je rajoute à ce
moment là une cuillère de cumin de cumin
wii 2 2 cuillères à café de cumin leur
salle un petit peu on n'est pas obligé
de salé et là je vois toujours et je me
pointe du moulin et là vous fêterez
c'est bien et pour aller un peu plus
vite vous pouvez vous mettre un petit
peu sur le fait mal comme ça ça faire
ramollir ne faut pas que ça cuit non non
il faut juste que ça fonde témoin
pendant ce temps je m'en vais à ses
hanches et mes cernes aussi en main
parce que toujours les apaches et
grossièrement investis sont assez moins
ouvertement parce que là je vous faire
une petite combine pour pouvoir farcir
les poivrons à avoir des arts ina
non non voir voilà c'est à dire voilà
alors vous voyez là une belle couleur
maintenant va émettre nos herbes on est
bien d'accord on ne me le fabricant
qu'on a mis l'oignon est tombé au beurre
on a un patrick a ensuite le cumin le
sel le poivre
ouais et maintenant on ajoute les dès
maintenant on ajoute les screens herbe
elle raille la ciboulette et à
l'estragon il ya le persil cerfeuil un
tout intenté à mélanger et h et à ses
adjoints et moi pendant ce temps que
vous muer je m'en vais vider les
poivrons à montrer moi bien non ça c'est
facile vous enlevez le chapeau et là
vous enlever toutes les graines qui sont
à l'intérieur
voyez vous avez vos propres roe qui sont
vidés et si possible se plaint vous le
faites un jour ou deux jours avant pour
la bonne rennais oui et puis tout le
poivron la pénétrer avec le fromage
c'est un petit peu un dérivé de du
fromage on croit le leak tolère mais
enfin ça c'est basquaise nous a envoyés
maintenant on va vous faire voir pour
faire la poche d'eau pourriez vous
prenez un sac en plastique découpée pour
qu'ils sont moins haut
alors donc votre sac en plastique et
vous mettez le fromage dans un coin
voilà vous mettez le fromage de
maintenant les cuisines ils ont des
poches mais en général jamais jamais de
poche alors ah bon non dans un ménage
jamais de poche à loaded au vote final
contre la pâtisserie
j'aimerais un sac en plastique en sacs
en plastique whip le vert où il ya eu
quoi que et là voyez donc finalement ça
à faire une poche alors là maintenant la
power stage est intense et là on va
couper ici et comme ça on va pouvoir
faire les poivrons farcis les amusant
bientôt les deux bouts on va se farcir
l'autre on met encore un petit coin
celui-là lé là hélas ce moment-là vous
remettez le champ pour et puis vous
allez me porter ça dans la glacière
jusqu'à après demain
eh bien vous verrez un ça va être
formidable
je pense et un gratin de macaronis ça ça
coûte pas cher dans toutes les saisons
et c'est facile à faire
avec quoi et bien le macaroni c'est vrai
bien avec un quasi de veau ou alors un
filet de veau ou alors deux ou trois
côtes de veau mais coupé ensemble c'est
à dire qui est l'os pour moi mon saut de
vaud il est bon quand il ya l'os avec
est un peu de gras surtout si le gras et
bien là et puis on accompagne on va
accompagner ça vous avez gratin de
macaronis il faut à cette époque de
l'année un bon roblochon et puis comme
gâteau comme pâtisseries comme dessert
on peut faire un bavarois aux pommes
c'est léger et c'est facile à faire bon
alors j'ai à peu près combien une
préparation au gratin de macaronis s'est
vite fait 20 minutes ça doit être fini
et puis je pense qu'on va peut-être voir
une côte rôtie avec sa wii un seul vin
c'est un vin qui est plein de soleil et
c'est bien agréable bien eh bien on va
commencer la recette si vous voulez s'il
vous plaît alors pour un gratin de
macaronis il faut des macaronis
oui ça me paraît évident oui mais alors
dans le temps trouver les vecteurs ils
ont maintenant il ya plus de maquereaux
nylon et pourquoi donc je ne sais pas je
vais me suis renseigné paris c'est une
question d'emballage les macaronis sont
tous coupés et à mâcon ninon pour moi
c'est beaucoup plus agréable car ils
pompaient - - lomé comme moi les cuire
dans du lait il n'y a pas de problème il
est cuit dans du lait oui pourquoi
ah parce que finalement quand tu y vas
gonflé il va gonfler plein de lait au
lieu de gonfler plein d'eau il sera plus
à louer mois le plus monté donc il nous
faut un peu d'ail
il nous faut un peu de muscade un peu de
persil un peu de soja mais dassault ge
dans le lake dans le lait froid vous
mettez tout ça dans le lait froid oui 1
oignon 1 petit oignon du beurre du lait
de la crème de la crème fleurette si on
veut vous savez la crème qui à bouillir
qu'on appelle c'est ça du fromage vous
ajoutez au dernier la crème du fromage
râpé et vous avez pour avoir du bon
fromage râpé
il faut toujours qu'il soit vous
rappeler au dernier moment c'est un
fromage râpé de 2,3 on n'a plus du tout
le même goût c'est à dire que quand la
ménagère va acheter son fromage
il faut qu'on lui rende devant elle je
mets du fromage râpé tout près du sel
est toujours du seul gros et du poivre
bon sur le pwa moulin bon point alors
maintenant
on va mettre à bouillir le lait est je
connais une petite formule pour pas que
le lait attache au fond de la casserole
c'est de beurrer mais beurré grâce main
le fond de la casserole et là ça empêche
de brûler et puis finalement ça donne
bon goût alors on va mettre le lait à
bouillir on verse le lait voilà on va le
salé est à peu près en salle à peu près
à 10 grammes au lien pour six personnes
combien de litres un livre de l'est un
litre de lait pour 6 pour 6 on y de sel
je m'en vais mettre la feuille de sauge
et c'est enfin une brindille de saône
on va mettre un peu de persil parce que
le persil aux citadins de bon goût et
puis on va éplucher un oignon et là
c'est un oignon blanc un oignon frais
c'est bien agréable
alors là donc l'oignon et l'oignon me
donner un peu de goût au lait et en même
temps à parfumer les macaronis et là on
va tout mettre à bouillir
voilà alors là on pense à ébullition
high line annoncé pour railler le plat
ça c'est pour mettre après voilà l on
l'a on met bouillir le lait voilà on va
faire après le probable c'est comme une
infusion de l'eau à bouillir le poids
bleuté l'animant toujours d'animaux et
toujours du poivre du moulin
parce que si c'est de l'autre ça vaut
rien alors là tu dois faire bouillir le
lait bien tranquillement on va le
laisser
et pour aller plus vite on va faire
aussi bouillir la crème
revoyez donc on va faire bouillir la
crème c'est la crème quai qui est pas
trop épaisses mais qui est quand même
belle hein alors pas les proportions
attendues pour six personnes
eh bien là c'est un bocal qui doivent
faire trois quarts de litre on va mettre
trois quarts de litre de crème or bien
sûr c'est cher et c'est gourmand l'alma
cronje pas cher mais le reste alors
attendez alors voilà et là maintenant ça
va bouillir bon et police à bout on va
éplucher une gousse d'ail
on va profiter de bien et y ait ce plat
et qui font un plat à ses pairs
là on épluche larry n'est plus une
petite bouche comme ça et on a eu le
plat toujours avant de le ré parce que
si on veut ravin ça dérape ça dérape et
sa guitare vous écraser un peu là y est
vous
hélas bien bien râpé
alors tout le plat bien bien bien ils
font là et ça donne bon goût voilà et là
encore on rubber mais on rubber
maintenant vous vous mettez après d'aidé
donc leur ya plus rien on attend
maintenant maintenant le lait va
bouillir le lait bout voilà alors donc
au grain et chaude la crème pas tout à
fait encore mais on va la faire chauffer
le persil et là qui m'a bien et on fait
bouillir donc le lait bout on va mettre
les mecs là monique un peu les boues
donc là on à peu près 500 g de macaronis
on a 500 g de macaronis alors on les met
à fuir et on va laisser sur un peu près
très peu de temps - d'habitude on va
laisser cuire à peu près 5 à 6 minutes
alors la volée remuer pour pas qu'ils
attachent alors ils sont durs quand on
est si oui mais ils vont finir de cuire
dans le plat et avec la crème laisser
cuire et puis là maintenant on revient
bien dans la crème
ah non non non vous voyez je la fais
chauffer c'est pour avancer parce que il
va y avoir un petit truc quand les mains
car au niveau on est prêts on va les
égoutter ne va pas les rafraîchir c'est
à dire qu'on va les sortir du jeune
femme est de froide barmaid aux fans de
se bien souvent les ménages elles ont eu
tort de rafraîchir une pâte à pain sur
les ménagères non j'aime bien les
managers addition disons les cuisinières
et on va mettre nos macaronis d'un plat
bouillant pour la 16e année de sel de
poivre de noix muscade et on va mettre
la crème après par dessus et au lieu de
laisser égratiné comme on laisse gratiné
quart d'heure vingt minutes on va les
laisser traîner c'est dans le four comme
on dit à lyon mais un four pas trop
chaud ou alors 180 degrés c'est à dire
là j'ai vu on l'a michaud fait à peu
près 180 degrés soit à peu près la force
5 à peu près là les mecs caraïbes où
tout va bien alors c'est presque accuse
maintenant sortez vous voilà ça fait à
peu près cinq minutes mais il faut quand
même laissé un peu pompé l'eau on savait
que quand on cuit dans du lait ça cuit
toujours un peu plus long c'est à dire
quand on fait une purée chez nous vous
avez ont fait la purée on fait le même
choix aussi très naturelle et macaroni
mai
et oui oui bon alors les macaronis sont
cuits le l'air bien oui vous avez vu on
va aller les éviter dans la passoire qui
entre autres c'est un tamis alors là on
y goûte et là on est bien d'accord nos
vallées là on a quelque chose pour
récupérer le lait alors on verse dedans
donc pour macaronis voiliers sont ils
sont juste pour ainsi dire blanchissant
patrick hein
ici on va très bien voilà je veux bien
que les femmes ça sert à quelque chose
si vous avez de temps en temps voilà
c'est pas tellement votre opinion alors
donc le la et l'a fait les macaronis
sont ici alors là maintenant on va
enlever donc temps que pour la peine dit
et c'est donc le new grove enlever le
persil la sauge qui donnent bon goût
donc voyez vous maccheroni ils sont
juste juste cuit et là maintenant on va
les poivres et de poivre du moulin 1 et
avait la litté des bonnes rampes et de
muscade
ça va me rappeler
et on va y mettre quelques noisettes de
beurre dessus on va tout mélanger le
plat beurré
aie aie aie et là on va mettre le coeur
qui va bien un bomber les macaronis
travail un petit peu avec les doigts on
fait comme on a l'habitude et maintenant
notre crème qui est bouilli on va la
mettre dessus un voile a envoyé s'est
imbibé de crem est mouillé le double de
double de ce qu'il faut un et alors là
maintenant il faut pas avoir pendant m
envoyer pour 400 g de macaronis pour
bien trois quarts crème
là on va me remettre un petit peu de la
froide un don ah oui non et voyez on va
mettre du fromage malade c'est gourmand
un gruyère et comme vous disais du
gruyère qui vient d'être fait mais
combien combien alors là il n'a bien 300
g
sans grands pour se dire 50 grammes pas
personnes 300 g pour 6 personnes
bon alors autre jour et chaud oui à 180
c là maintenant qu'on va y mettre dans
le four le font attention à ne pas vous
brûler parce que c'est chaud on va
freiner on prend les torts sont hélas on
va laisser traîne assez traînasser dans
le four alors je m'emmêle le poser dans
le four voilà voilà
alors vous surveillez bien que votre
four ils soient chauds par la voûte
ainsi vous pouvez est un petit peu de
sous alors voyez il est à 180 est
maintenant dans 40 minutes on reviendra
boire mais de temps en temps sur veille
quand même oui mais risquons pas de
brûler quand même maintenant et puis
vous savez on va peut-être aller voir où
ça pousse et macaroni ça serait une
bonne idée
oui
[Musique]
l'on croit savoir que les patrons
étaient en quelque sorte inventé en
extrême orient en chine
en fait elles ont été connus en europe
par marco polo qui les a importé à
venise au 14e siècle
donc depuis cette époque voyez le chemin
considérable qu'ont parcourus les pattes
puisque d'un domaine parfaitement
ménages et artisanale petit à petit les
pâtes ont pris une place prépondérante
importante dans la nutrition moderne
[Musique]
spaghettis macaronis bout katyn
ce sont les pâtes longue mais encore un
pad courte des coquillettes des nouilles
des taux recettes des collerettes etc
etc
ses pattes vous pouvez les préparer tout
simplement aubert mais aussi à la tomate
à la sauce aux champignons en grata au
four en soupe
en dessert en salades etc etc à l'infini
en quelque sorte
il ne dépend que de votre imagination
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans les pays où l'on constate où l'on
consomme beaucoup de pommes de terre on
consomme peu de pâtes et de riz c'est le
cas de la belgique que dans les pays où
on consomme beaucoup de pâtes on
consomme un peu moindre y est presque
pas de pommes de terre
c'est le cas de l'italie et l'on
constate qu'en france pays équilibré
nous mangeons les consommateurs français
consomment à peu près harmonieusement
des pâtes du riz et des pommes de terre
[Musique]
bon ça y est les 40 minutes moi je suis
prêt oui on est les macaronis oui ça
fait même qu'un de cinq minutes qui sont
alors ils ont assez très là c'est comme
ça ah oui mars à d'autres ailleurs allez
olla là où ce qu'ils sont beaux ils sont
trois ils auraient supporté presque
encore 5 minutes et non mais non remplie
c'est chaud alors vous voyez là toutes
les touts les macaronis ils ont
gourmands ils ont ils ont compris qu'il
n'y a plus rien
non qu'ils ont un bébé de krems de
beurre de noix muscade du goût du nassau
ou bon il va toujours vient d'annuler
[Musique]